moments for more than 2500 students and
staff at East High School in Denver
yesterday after a shooting on campus
police say two staff members Gerald
Mason and Eric Sinclair were conducting
a routine pat down search of 17 year old
Austin Lyle when a handgun was
discovered in his possession that's when
police say the student shot both men
this particular student actually had a
safety plan that was in place where they
were to be searched at the beginning of
the school day every day they had been
searched previously to today and had
never had a weapon on them before school
officials have not provided a reason why
the teenager required Pat Downs other
than citing his past Behavior nor had
they said how many other students are on
a similar safety plan at this point
nobody feels safe students and parents
are demanding answers and
actions no more words
into your office